just frame for us your thoughts on debt
for a second how do you think about debt
as an absolute construct or a relative
construct especially sovereign debt you
know the there is a US debt but then
there are also every other 182 countries
who have a ton of debt and so how do you
think about debt debt to GDP relatively
and in absolute terms for any country
and quite
often many countries because they go
through the cycle together as they did
in the
30s um what happens is that rid is
relative to incomes and what that means
mechanistically is that Debt Service
payments rise relative to incomes and um
and so it squeezes out consumption as
this compounds and what happens is
there's a realization that they have to
print money so I think you're going to
see in the next downturn another move to
print money there are certain things
that are going going on now that means
that the big risk comes when they don't
want to hold those bonds anymore okay
because the supply demand think about
that Supply
demand has a deficit it has to borrow
and so it sells its bonds who are the
buyers of the bonds why do they buy the
buyers of the bonds buy because there's
an attractive return not only do you
have to sell those amounts of bonds but
when they start to realize that I'm not
getting good returns on those bonds they
can sell those bonds they were
31 trillion a bond what they own instead
uh they always own um uh uh tangible
things and those things can also be it
could be
equities it could be other many other
things it could be gold okay gold has
always been um accepted as a money
because it's nobody else's there's a
saying gold is the only asset you can
have that not somebody else's is
liability in other words you're
dependent on getting paid you can have
that at intrinsic value and for a long
period of time it's been valued and you
can move it between countries but also
um different countries Prosper so you'll
see the countries some of the countries
that we mentioned they will prosper
through that the United States made most
of its money because it didn't end to
the war it was before on World War II
and World War I the United States became
the richest country because of the money
it made before it entered the war
so those countries will prosper and in
those countries then certain real estate
of prop hard assets but where you have
that is very very important